this has been a fun offseason where I
don't have to get up early in the
morning and get ready so physically I'm
retired physically retired as a clear
hard was it mentally to retire from the
game ah it wasn't you know I people have
asked me that question is just something
that I've known I just just felt right
the time was right for me and and
mentally I feel great about it you're
only 40 years old thank you say that
again only only 40 year and athlete
where do use a new 25 okay because when
you're at athlete they say your old at
30 so thank you so do you feel like in a
way you've been preparing for this
moment your whole life this moment where
you're actually now going to take the
money that you made and invest it and
grow it yeah well you know for me I
think you know people just make an
assumption that you know you retire and
you just jump into the business world
that there's you know a lot of things
that I've learned along the way whether
it be involved marketing deals
endorsement deals investments paying
attention that there's things that you
learn I mean through my foundation
there's a lot of things in business that
I've learned so it's not like I'm just
jumping into it i'm just now I'm just
more involved what's the biggest thing
you've learned so far oh and business
patience you know I'm coming from a
career where it's instant gratification
or failure business it takes a little
time but I've also learned what I don't
know I'm always good at what I don't
know so I try to learn from people that
are much smarter than me have you turned
to any any billionaires or entrepreneurs
or CEOs for advice of course of course
yeah like I said like to surround myself
with people that I can learn from and
I've learned quite a bit from from a lot
of the people that I've met over the
last year's ingénue e the CEO Pepsi have
gotten close to her over the years she
brought me out to Davos a couple years
ago and and she really trusted me into
the business scene and made me extremely
uncomfortable so I've learned quite a
bit from her I mean that's that's
someone that's come to mind Michael
Jordan's like a big brother to me I mean
someone that has some similarities in
terms of playing in the sports world and
then going in a team ownership which one
day I'd like to do so I learned a lot
from him as well how close are you to
making a decision on that
this is something that's died I don't
know enough about it to jump in the team
ownership like I said well my biggest
fear in life is being unprepared so I
make sure that I'm fully prepared before
I would do something like that so no
I've got time for that so 12 months from
now we won't see Derek Jeter team owner
you have some money for me I think I
might need to get some from you if you
were to own a team would it be a
baseball team Murr could you look at
somewhere else no I mean I I baseball's
what I know I like i said i don't like
to be unprepared and I don't know enough
about the other sports too to own a team
and I'd like to call the shots so
therefore I like to know what I'm doing
so now I'll stick with what I know that
is of course Yankees legend Derek Jeter
and founding publisher of the players
Tribune and by the way we got a comment
from PepsiCo CEO indra nooyi she
responded to comments by Jeter in that
interview she said quote Derek Jeter is
a joy to work with the same qualities
that made Derek one of the greatest
on-field leaders of our generation will
make him successful in business I
learned a lot from Derek leadership of
the Yankees and all of us at pepsico
look forward to his next act so they